[Applause]
why
did your boy connor shout out to proper
12 yeah stiff dustin on a charity bro
no come on stop it come on i might tell
you right now as one of my closest
friends
yeah you donated the money i'll be
honest with you i'm [ __ ] if he
says something
yeah it's done i would not not even i
can guess so that must be on their end
i'm telling you right now so i'll i'll
make an argument for connor he said
no no no i'm telling you right now no no
no my closest friends yo he's like one
of those guys like you give a handshake
you know like you know what you're from
new york guy gives you a handshake yeah
you know that's [ __ ]
yeah about that [ __ ] anything
he's ever said to me like that
al's had 10 handshakes in his life and
he's six and four
okay no no there's no worries ten and
ten not six or four
no that's a good idea yeah we're gonna
put it down you're good put it in my
mouth brother
what did he say i'm not sure what he's
good at
come over here all right so this is the
argument i'll make for connor go ahead
connor said we want to know where the
money's going if i give you half a
million i need to know where
or else sometimes it ends up in people's
pockets that's true 100 with a lot of
these
charities like i even think if you give
money to red cross something like 90
percent of the money you give
you guys live in europe in europe right
yes yeah whenever
you remember when i challenged you to
spawn in new york you remember they were
running
i was doing a charity case for you
aussie y'all may work this guy in the
morning like half hung over bro
hey bro we're gonna spar in jiu jitsu
yeah give me give me girl right now i'll
do it on camera right now
i will spar you and you just give me one
of these brother [ __ ] i'm nice at jiu
jitsu all of a sudden
right now you're coming along though i
could do it at la mario don't worry your
legs bro
these toothpicks oh you got two big arms
and i got you
[ __ ] more athletic than your
bro that guy he might be
but will you take it down no who was
taking it down to jujitsu
i put the jew in jujitsu my friend you
think you're a jewish
because he's wearing extra large he's
like a small
i'ma be honest it's a medium but notice
we're making that [ __ ] look excellent
it's just stuck it's [ __ ]
shopping at baby gap i swear to god
he's already gone nobody's gonna see the
he's like extra small in reality huh
he's like extra small in reality but
yeah
yo yo he's small but oh yeah
yeah he's small bro yeah
my voice is [ __ ] up but yo yo you're
a good ass friend you know why they say
he's extra small he goes like this
what'd you say yeah
i'm high bro that's my guy
keep talking [ __ ] he gonna [ __ ] your
cute-ass brother bro
[ __ ] cute-ass brother bro come on it
doesn't bother you thank you
guys come on cameron is cute
he looked like vampire jake paul
but his whole style is a paul brother
don't that's why he got that dog
thoughts might hit that bro
just off the street off the street you
make me laugh
right now i saw you going down
you don't lost one round with him bro
when it was in the bedroom
what is happening i don't know you're so
competitive
it's like no he'll out [ __ ] you yeah my
friend's gonna
make your night bro
yo you guys are [ __ ] wild right now
oh [ __ ] all right
this policies do better than alex
jones's one bro you think you think we
got it oh
yeah i swear to god though i was really
upset when i got [ __ ] taken down what
did i say to you right away
when the the podcast got taken down or
the the episode on youtube remember i
was
y'all i killed alex jones episode get
taken down you did say that and then you
were like do you know why you're gonna
take it out i want to know
why it got taken down yeah uh he lied a
lot
they were taking the fact that's the
main reason that's pretty much what it
is
he said the vaccine gives you cancer so
that just took a tough to be honest
i don't know i don't i believe him bro i
believe him more than anybody else
that's the thing he's 80 right about
everything right he was black
he's like he was about to i love the
dude but he's about to take a hard time
bro he's [ __ ] very red turkey and
[ __ ] funny
that guy's a tank bro yeah the only
thing that take him out is a clinton
that's the only way you get alex jones
out here that guy's a
he said he stopped the car with the kids
in it recently
he punched the hood yeah he punches
that [ __ ] he's bringing like a
94 chevy bro if i can design the phone
like this because i ain't driving bro
the poor driver's like where am i
transferring kids because i didn't even
know what he was doing bro
what did they find out happened with
that i don't know it wasn't some
pedophile right now i'll be honest with
you my voice is like [ __ ] up right now
yeah but it's okay i've been they can
ask all night bro
[Laughter]
that's not even his brother bro he found
that [ __ ] he's got
his own shirt because that's certain
he's been following me since we got back
[Laughter]
in my pocket um conor dustin who wins
objectively speaking actually i don't
want you to be objective i just want you
to lay in
that [ __ ] i'm telling you bro
like that's a different animal
but what have you heard what they're
saying that like he's running the camp
and when he runs the camp
he's not pushing as far not sure it's
not not true so his coach is still
running yeah yeah bro he's
well that's that [ __ ] is a he's
a killer bro i'm telling you so what
happened in that fight
i mean that like i mean i mean it wasn't
just the light kicks you know i think he
just had different gameplay
he was a little bit more boxing heavy
for the for the because he he was
looking at pacquiao you know
he's the one ringing for yeah and he's
like oh dustin's the southpaw so i'll
get in there and i'll mix it up with the
southpaw well this fight
i can almost guarantee you the knockout
like really i'll play any money was off
though an hour ago
yeah did you hear that he said the fight
was off because he was upset actually
these are really funny tweets
i i really don't i prefer no no i
promise
you guys got the you know you guys don't
have any [ __ ] there's a sasha's
festival
what what is that you want some titties
there were some sausages first what is
that
that's what he was doing on the boat
[Laughter]
sasha's best bro you're from new york no
dude i don't what's a sausage face what
do you do every day bro i saw your face
wait
hang out with guys and suck their dicks
oh
bro what is the most famous what is the
most famous polish
cuisine and as i say no one cares about
them
it's sausage it's kielbasa dude is it
really yeah are you polish
no but he's scottish i'm scottish indian
food though
the best food ever you don't know myself
chicken yo he [ __ ] that up
[Laughter]
called be honest yeah